petit à petit on s'est vus on à échanger
sur les problématiques des commerçants
donc moi j'avais beaucoup à apprendre
puisque puisque j'étais pas du tout dans
le domaine et ensuite est venue ma cette
crise sanitaire ou là
notre comment dire solidarité s'est
renforcée justement pour faire face à
cette crise qui générait des problèmes
économiques
mettez moi on est dans la restauration
donc il peut m'arriver moi parce que
justement crise sanitaire j'ai une
employée qui est à temps partiel donc je
suis moins disponibles voilà j'ai plus
de crème fraîche appel à m hind dehiba
portes de la crème fraîche
il a plus de 9 j'ai vu des 100 des oeufs
des tomates voilà des matières premières
dont on a besoin
olga qui est conseiller municipal à la
mairie
son objectif c'est de nous accompagner
est ce cette micro associations de
commerçants essaient d'en faire quelque
chose
à l'ampleur de saint cyr avec l'ensemble
des commerçants de saint cyr